awesome thank you welcome to the first I
think silicon valley scale warrior
meetup we call it the scale warrior meet
up because all these guys here are
pushing the limits of scale when it
comes to fast data big data and so we
want to have you this is the first of
what we hope will be more meetups where
you guys can sit and exchange war
stories I'd like to introduce the our
moderator for panel this morning out
this morning this evening Dave fine leap
he is author of a soon-to-be published
book called Big Data demystified and
he's also producer of big data TV and
big data landscape com he's also an
entrepreneur founder of speechpad in an
awesome service that we use actually
that does audio video transcription &
captioning and what else have you done
well serial entrepreneur bunch of
companies bought by HP and EMC and just
a happenin guy so thank you welcome Dave
thanks Monica well it's great to have
everyone so bad a year and a half ago I
was training for this event called Iron
Man France and an iron man for those of
you who don't know is a 2.4 miles swim
and a 112-mile bike followed by a full
26.2 mile marathon that's a good time I
highly recommend it has anyone done a
marathon or a 10k or okay so you've all
done events like this and you got like
the garmin gps watch and I was you know
obsessed with my data and so I was
tracking everything about myself like so
many people do and got really interested
in the big data space started
researching it around the same time
company called splunk went public and I
thought gosh you might be interesting to
see how the public market interest in
big data companies related to my own
personal interest in big data and so
that's kind of how I got into the space
after being an enterprise storage guy
for a number of years so we have a
really really great panel tonight to
talk about all aspects
big data we're going to spend about 30
minutes or so with questions that we've
all prepared and then we'll open it up
to the audience and you should feel free
to ask away of anything you'd like to
know from these guys so we'll start with
intros down here on the Left we have
brian from aerospike hi I'm CTO okay and
that maybe tell us a little bit what
aerospike does and what you do there
sure aerospike is a distributed database
and we're used very much in the
advertising industry for user profile
storage and real-time analytics we
specialize in SSD and space in the one
to terra ten terabyte areas we're here
partially because I AdTech San Francisco
for those of you who were at the ad tech
conference the last few days great great
and steve has been at meta markets for
what all of six weeks six weeks but I
expect the full pitch on what the
company does so what what does menta
markets do and what do you do there sure
so I'm vice president of engineering at
meta markets I just moved over there
from from Terra Cotta where I was for
eight and a half years like I was the
first engineer on that project and then
got to grow the team and essentially be
part of selling that company which was
kind of cool and then and then we over
to meta markets which is a really
exciting transition for me so what we do
is is we focus on sort of being able to
take all of your data most in the ad
tech space right now but take all of
your data so it's the billions of events
that come in around things like ad
impressions revenue clicks I'm not from
the ad world so I'm still learning all
that the nomenclature xdrive the
clickstream and we end up sort of
normalizing it in real time in and so
we're sort of real-time on the way in
and then also real time and your ability
to sort of use pivot tables and
visualize and slice and dice your data
uh so it's sort of got the two sides of
real time and and and the massive
amounts of data and then the other thing
that makes it cool is that it's
so like you know customers can sort of
just connect their all these billions
and billions of events into into our our
fun little world where we munge it and
and allow you to do these analytics and
pivot tables and graphs and
visualizations did that make sense cool
it was great right all right thanks
thanks for the intro so here we have
Scott Scott spends what a week a month
here and the rest of your life is in
Little Rock so tell us about your
company that I live in little rock or
the foster city marriott hotel depending
on what time of the year I'm the
enterprise architect lead for all the
transactional systems at acxiom
corporation axiom has been treated for t
plus year company traditionally dealing
with data analytics and
software-as-a-service a lot in the
offline world we've made a big push in
the last year to get in the ad space in
the real-time world made our public
announcement in March our DMP is going
to be up in full GA in October berardi
and alpha with two clients already taken
about 350 million transactions that
clicks a day yeah great all right well
thanks so much John you're with Apple
oven and I gotta ask you where did the
name come from well we were looking at
ads on mobile which is what we do and we
noticed that apps were kind of the key
thing that was going on this is a year
or two ago when you went to look at
mobile ad domain names or app domain
names everything was taken but we took
her inspiration from Napoleon Dynamite
care for the Nick lovin character and we
happen to find this domain name so we
ended up with a pillow
so it is it's you know the mobile ad
space on iOS and Android we're an ad
network that connects publishers and
advertisers and the key difference on
the mobile space is that the data comes
through the apps so apps are kind of a
key unit and there's not really the same
equivalent as there is in the web of the
cookie and the time users via cookie so
you have to deal with identities through
apps and that's why we connect with data
partners and use big databases and deal
with data all the time just to be able
to sort of better ads on the mobile side
great all right and GP down at the end
here you are with brightroll and we're
one of the cofounders of aerospike as
well that's true anxious history by now
so I'm a senior staff engineer at Brett
roll and I burn roll the senior staff
engineers are kind of engineers without
portfolio we work on whatever a sort of
the most important thing for us to work
on at any point of time is so I've spent
the last six eight months focusing on
sort of our set of problems around
real-time data so bright roll depending
on the month is either the first or
second largest video ad network in the
world we receive and neck and neck with
Google as you can imagine we have an
immense amount of data flowing through
our system some of it we can report on
will sort of traditional Big Data kind
of methodologies other stuff we are in
other use cases we need some way of
acting on that data very quickly and
that we would class sort of as a real
time data problems so that's sort of
where I've been spending a majority of
my time great all right well maybe we
can on that note talk a little about the
scale of all the different companies so
just out of curiosity how many people
here have technical backgrounds and
heavily technical doing day-to-day
engineering great and from the ad world
okay mix great so maybe you can talk
about some of the specific technologies
that you use and
you know what kind of scale you're at
and some of the challenges day to day
and we'll start with with that from each
of our panelists you're done get what
you want so yeah I want me to go back oh
yeah so last time I checked which was
about an hour ago we do on the close
order of 16 billion adds a month which
is a reasonably significant amount of
traffic the display ad company would do
more but for video that's pretty good as
far as specific technology so right now
we sort of as I said break it into two
parts there's sort of a historical data
reporting part that right now has for
quite a while been done with internal
tools that were written quite a while
ago we're in the process of trenches
transitioning those two mixture of
Hadoop and HBase for the real-time data
projects where you're trying to make a
decision about what ad to show someone
and that kind of real time when to 100
millisecond window it's all code built
on top of aerospike which has been
working pretty well so far all right
great John how what do you do that's
kind of unique in the for mobile apps in
particular what are some of the
challenges there well i mean i think
that the stack that i think about is we
have a real-time querying component we
have a kind of more batch mode analysis
component and then we have a data
warehouse that may be the unique thing
is the number of profiles that we have
you're dealing with the number of people
that have smartphones in the world so
the plan is it's on the order of 2
billion were near the billion mark in
terms of profiles so we look at
different components of the stack we use
aerospike for kind of the real-time
access to the profile data at the edge
so it's essentially a very good cash
tool for us we'll move data up from the
warehouse component into the edge
component I mean that the big trend that
we're
looking at is and kind of what GP was
saying is more and more stuff is going
real time you know our our stats are
basically five minutes off real time
right now and we want to close that gap
to be less than a minute and so that has
been the trend for us as more stuff
moves to the edge more stuff moves in
memory and analysis has to happen in
parallel and I think that'll be a
consistent theme for everybody Great
Scott what what are some of the
technologies you use and what are some
of the challenges for your business the
differentiator that we're going after in
the ad space in the DM peach space is
taking the offline data that we have we
manage have probably the top 100 fortune
500 companies as our clients in the
offline managing their marketing and
their offline marketing bringing that
into the online world so you can get it
to other systems that they can make
decisions and ads based off of not only
the clients data but also our data
assets so putting that all on the edge
and be able to do it in we've clocked
ourselves internally 10mil 10
milliseconds to do to reach one right to
aerospike we're using aerospike as the
edge store did a bunch of side-by-side
comparisons this time last year there in
the ad space they're built for the ad
space it was just just work so that's
what we're going to be doing we're in
alpha right now starting to push data to
for a couple different clients getting
that on-boarded into aerospoke and then
pushing that out during that serves and
you know great great all right well over
to this side I didn't mean to ignore you
guys ever again so talk a little about
John you're a terracotta yet which is
really a big data company even before
Big Data was a term right I would say
maybe could spend a minute and talk
about some of the things you learned
there
but you know a little more about the
current things that are going on so it
was interesting you know when we started
terracotta you know terracotta is
written is written in Java and it was
and you know a 30 gig customer was a big
customer for us I don't know if how many
people remember even probably four or
five years ago that you could actually
say that with a straight face then and
people wouldn't laugh at you and point
at you and then and then I was talking
to a buddy of mine over at Pandora and
and he was using memcache actually in
they said with you know why do you use
memcache you're a Java shop and and he
was saying well when you have a lot of
data there's two things one when you
have a lot of data sure you can
distribute it and you can do it in
various kinds of databases but as far as
operations goes the thing he valued most
was predictability and I really stuck
with me like so one of the fundamental
things about about terra cotta from that
sort of maybe your past that when I we
solve the problem at moving forward was
being able to go scale up and scale out
so you know get to that knee in the
curve maybe up to like a terabyte of ram
per machine and be able to give results
extremely predictably in high end with
high availability and and I think the
operational character and the lesson I
took away from that is at the
operational characteristics of some of
these data stores and how they're
managed in production and how you
achieve 24 x 7 x 365 x 10 is literally
as important or maybe even more
important than things like whether it's
the transactional guarantees versus
eventual consistency and more important
than you know whether it has every kind
of analytic or every kind of search you
could possibly do and what do you so
could you want to make something
predictable and predict you know yeah
very reliable what do you do in order to
make that a reality so you know it's
interesting there's a couple things you
have to do one is you have to measure it
the very first thing we had to do is
create tests that in a detailed way
measured you know the standard
deviations and the predictability and
focus on those Layton sees and then in
the Java world ah for those of you who
have
with garbage collected programming
languages well you know what we did and
was we built essentially a off heap
store that could that we could easily
scale to a terabyte it was preet you
know would be pre-allocated and and
built our own sort of almost our own
memory like so Java I don't get too
detailed because I might pour some half
of some percentage of the room but the
reason why garbage collection is hard is
because you're dealing with graph data
right like everything is referencing
each other you have to figure out what's
old and and uninteresting and then
there's of course the compaction problem
but the observation was is yeah that's a
really hard problem but but it's not
really that hard of a problem in the
cash cuz its key value and those keys
and Dives aren't talking to each other
and so we were able to sort of leverage
some of the things that existed and this
sort of this observation to be able to
build data stores that scale up to like
literally a terabyte per node and more
and billions of entries and we had
already solved a lot of the other hard
problems around you know having passives
or hot standbys and and and availability
problems because in the 30 gig world we
already needed all that so I don't know
if I answered your question yeah yeah I
know that's a bunch of random fence
that's great I guess on the the next
step was the druid side sorry not to
monopolize time but that's you know in
the in the druid world we you know it
started out very early on so I like
druid is the open source database that
we use answering the question about what
the technology stack is is the open
source database we use to provide all
that the analytics for metal markets and
for us it's literally like each customer
is providing us billions of events a day
and you know I wouldn't say we're we're
up to petabytes yet but we'll probably
get up up to petabytes of data you know
by the end of this year so it's a lot of
data when your ass ass and and even for
us it's the same thing we're very
focused on operational characteristics
95th percentile Layton sees or 99th
percentile agencies 24 x 7 x 365 x 10 so
anyway I don't like raisins right so
Brian you're you know you started
aerospike along with
folks of course what what are some of
the reasons you felt like you had to
build a new database and we've had lots
of databases in the world for a long
time why build a new one that's a great
question some some days I still wonder
that oh it's good you're fighting the
kid funny thank you so I remember the
day when GP since he's got an ops
background he was smoking outside the
building i don't know why ops all Ops
guys smoke but Wednesday's I'm gonna go
but but and maybe every way every week
he would say hey let's start a company
that does acts and one day finally said
let's actually build a predictable
database that stays up under load and
I'm like you're right because there
isn't one of those I mean you can you
know you everyone had to roll their own
at that point and when I left that
company I had three different companies
call me up one was the netflix guys one
was a kleiner funded security startup
and the other one was you remember
danger the hip hop you know that little
cell phone thing as a friend of Monica's
are from Apple called me up and said our
servers are in real bad shape
everything's about to go down horribly
and we're about to lose everyone's email
this was about two months before it
actually happened so Andy was actually
smart enough but I didn't say yes to
that but three different people called
me up the same week said come and build
a townhouse project build an in-house
team to solve server scalability with
extreme uptime and predictability so you
know I'm not that much of a fool so
that's that's essentially why because as
you're saying the hard problem is this
predictability and let me tell you one
sort of side story on that I was at a
video server company and called
starlight networks in the early 90s and
is my second job out of college and they
described the file system for video
serving streaming video serving and they
said we randomly allocate blocks and
scatter them all over the disk and I was
like that's insane it's streaming why
don't you put them all together and they
said when it's random then you know that
the performance at the beginning there's
no such things fragmentation because
it's always perfectly fragmented all the
time you never get the advantage of
streaming on disk so if it's fast enough
on day one it's fast enough on day one
hundred it's fast enough ten years later
so I call this the engineering
philosophy of best worst case
performance engineer for the worst case
use random techniques which GP is
exploited to a great extent in aerospike
and make sure that everything's random
so that you always get worst case then
optimized like crazy to make worse case
super super fast that gets you
predictability and I learned that from a
couple of crusty old guys who are old
freecom guys designing this crazy file
system that's great so when people talk
about Big Data they often say Hadoop and
I'm curious what you guys think of that
is that you know the should that be soon
amna synonymous with big data is it
relevant today is that you know a key
part of what you're doing or or not so
much and feel free to jump in anywhere
I'll jump in the UH we've been doing big
data before it was named Big Data and
they in the batch world managing all
these customer profiles and for all of
our large clients it just happens the
same problems and predictability you
have running in an ETL or own grid
environment now you're running
Hadoop environment so well in the
migration phase is starting to use
off-the-shelf technologies versus what
we built our ourselves but it it's the
same thing just over again mmm said I
mean my take is look Hadoop it Hadoop
gets to be gets to name it because they
were there first it's kind of like
asteroids or stars or the moon or not
the moon and legislative but you know
like celestial bodies get named by the
first person who sort of gets there and
look Hadoop is amazing right it reduced
the cost of managing data by essentially
1000x and that it it's not that they did
something that was so hard or were
different it's that they did it well and
they did it cheaply and they made it
approachable somewhat approachable but
it is I mean at least to this point
mostly bad right so I mean we used to do
for certain things you know when we want
to lunge a bunch of data and and and in
a batch rated waste probably the
cheapest best way to do so and the
Hadoop name is probably going to keep
growing over time and keep pulling in
more things and eat already who do what
does he do well is it MapReduce yeah
that's part of it but it's kind of you
know growing to mean a whole ecosystem
of things and you know they earned that
through being being first but it'll be a
while I think when you start from that
it's sort of like what you're saying
when you start from batch it's hard to
become the predictable I think story
that has to be kind of your your goal I
think upfront it's going to be I think a
while before they can get to compete
with like the arrow spikes of the
midlane sees you're talking about you're
different and that you're addictive it
is yet they're trying they're trying to
get there but it's a you know it's
actually easier to start from scratch
and get to a predictable big real-time
data store than it is to start from a
batch 1 and convert it into a I think
anyway I mean one thing I'd say about
Hadoop is you have to think about where
it came from we're mostly add technology
people it's a copy of what Google
built-in you know the late 90s and they
had a five-year technology lead on the
other
companies that were trying to do similar
things and now Hadoop is actually kind
of a I think of it as kind of a somewhat
mature os-level thing that's the
entry-level thing for big data but if
you look where Google and the people
that the facebooks of the world are
right now they've passed you know kind
of what Hadoop with its batch limitation
they're all putting stuff into memory
and using massively parallel techniques
of different different you know kind of
algorithms and compute graphs to be able
to do more stuff so I mean that's where
you know if you're kind of more towards
the edge you have to be more like what
those there's only a handful of
companies in the world really doing that
and there's no off-the-shelf single
production system that handles it but in
the meantime I think Hadoop's great for
you know kind of enabling mass adoption
of this kind of parallel OS for doing
computation so it's a pretty interesting
thing but if you want to follow google
you have to kind of go where that you
know there it just 11 stories you know
there if you'd remember their indexes
used to take a month to update in there
like two thousand two thousand if you
put a new link on the web it wouldn't
show up in the Google index now if you
put a new link on the web it shows up in
30 seconds or something like that so
that's the difference between kind of
batch mode which the original system was
and then yahoo system was and now what's
happening with kind of real time
updating a parallel parallel computation
great will you spend a minute on video
and what some of the unique aspects of
video serving and challenges and that
so actually it's a little bit of a
difficult question for me to answer
because from the perspective of a video
advertising company you can make a
pretty good argument that if you're
going to show video ad you're going to
he's the same technology as showing a
display out and we aren't really
involved in the data plane so much I
think we would say that's largely been a
solved problem by the CDN so maybe I'll
turn the question around an answer you
with a dupe question and said um I think
that Hadoop has certainly come a really
long way from when I first heard about
it however many years ago that was a
long time anyway um Hadoop remains a
very good tool for I have an immense
amount of data I want to process it I
want to distill something out of it and
deal with it later I want to absolutely
correct result as close as I can get to
on I'm totally prepared to wait for it
and there are problems where that is
absolutely the correct solution if I
have to write a billing system for for
example 16 odd billion ad impressions a
month I'm probably going to use Hadoop
because if it comes out at 1203 versus
1204 I'm all right with the extra minute
like that's okay but if I have some
problem where a user just showed up I
have a hundred milliseconds to pick
which ad they're going to see from which
provider clearly going to Hadoop isn't
going to be the right direction and they
are trying mostly through sort of let's
see if products in the ephemera like
HBase to try and get that response time
down to make their computations turn
around quicker I think they have a long
way to go it's it is really really hard
to take something that was fundamentally
designed for batch processing where
we're to some degree they they have a
long history of punting on the hard part
of the problem like I vividly remember
the day as Brian alluded to earlier I've
sort of split my career half between
operations in half between software
engineering I vividly remember the day
unfortunate i was on the up side the day
I learned this lesson that the secondary
name node really wasn't a backup primary
name node so much
when your primary namenode goes down the
entire system stops working for four
hours as you frantically have texts out
trying to swap things around it's like
I'm glad I wasn't relying on this for
the you know something that I needed 100
milliseconds ago four hours ago so I
think they're starting to make good
progress they have a long way to go that
convert in that space that's a that's a
very hard transition to make on the
other hand the tree of technology Forks
all the time we always come up with
different solutions to different
problems there the context of the
problems we're trying to solve always
changes so you know new tools solve new
problems great great so I'm going to
open it up to oh please yeah okay what
I'm really excited about with Hadoop is
what it's done for programmers right so
one of the interest the problems with
sequel and one of the reasons why no
sequels started existing was there are
problems things you can express in
sequel which are inherently non scalable
and require a single machine right there
are certain kinds of large-scale joints
which if you're doing them in a
distributed system they're always going
to perform very very poorly and what
MapReduce did not not to do per se but
MapReduce is it's exposed an entire
generation now of programmers to the
world of hey I'm going to do this
different certain kind of functional
programming I'm going to think of my
data as a data stream and I can only
express operations that scale that's
kind of great and I think that was a lot
of the brilliance of the MapReduce
programming model now I think we're all
going to go beyond or there's going to
be so many different twists on MapReduce
programming right because 10gen and mom
goes support it it's obviously in our
future to support some very aggressive
and interesting forms of MapReduce on
the sub second basis but but what it's
done in terms of programming and
programming languages bring bringing
functional programming at scale to the
fore i think is the brilliance of what i
do did it's great so i'd love to open it
up to questions from the audience before
i do that i do have one question upon
kind of an entrepreneurial note so
you're
all sort of raise money and you know
been out fundraising starting companies
from scratch can you spend a moment and
just talk about how you went about that
and you know what some of the memorable
moments were and i'm sure there were a
great many but some of the things you've
learned from starting your own companies
after be careful here not to embarrass
the guy at the other end of the table I
raise that's why you're inside it's all
good no no i didn't i know we were gonna
stick to big data and i didn't prepare
you with entrepreneur questions but so
about that i'll give my side of the
story on the the what what led to
aerospike so two companies i had worked
at in quick succession so I was on the
lead engineer on the operation side with
a three-year three really good
co-workers at salesforce com so we took
them sort of through their IPO through
about two years post and when I started
there they were on the cover of The Wall
Street Journal it seemed like every
other day because they were broken and
we got them off the front page the wall
street journal because of that which was
really good it was a very hard very
expensive journey because we didn't
really have the technology that we
needed to make it work the way we knew
that it should so we did things like you
attach a document to a case we're just
going to store that as a serialized blob
and Oracle so our Oracle database at the
time we left was running on four hundred
CPUs and four terabytes of ram and
probably 16,000 hard drives circa 2006
and you know periodically a node would
crash so sales force would be down for
two hours so after that I was really fed
up with databases that didn't stay
running databases that cost a hundred
thousand dollars cpu and databases that
didn't have consistent performance so I
was very very fed up with that so I left
Salesforce I wanted to get back into the
software engineering side of the world
so I started a little tronix to me I
joined a little kleiner perkins back
company called aggregate knowledge which
at the time we were trying to do
behavioral product
recommendation so is that fourth or
fifth employees something like that and
I was working on the backend
recommendation systems which was
interesting because it was a real time
problem a user shows up you can imagine
trying to compute something like Amazon
style people who viewed this bought that
you have 150 milliseconds to try and
compute that in real time you have half
a billion behavioral data points how do
you do that okay well that turns out to
be hard the math interestingly is really
easy it's how do you get to and from the
data really fast so I needed a
co-conspirator this you know I put
something together but I needed extra
help and I happen to find Brian over
there sunyac icky and I kind of teamed
up to work on that problem and one day
you know I was in fact outside smoking
and it has sort of occurred to me the
night before that though those were
really related problems the same
database problems i was running into
sales i had to run into its sales force
like this thing keeps crashing and hey i
need this really really fast but not
necessarily relational data storage
model for small transy objects-- how do
you how about we like put those together
because there's nothing that does
anything like that um so I suckered
Brian into it which is I was lucky or he
saw my brilliance you can take it either
way uh which is the I was bored possible
um the experience of entrepreneurship is
a incredible ride it is a roller coaster
of the first order it is the highest
highs and the lowest lows I would not
like if you have an idea but you believe
in then you should go do it it is that
simple like just go do it with that
being said like you part of the process
of entrepreneurship is building this
thing from nothing and but what you're
building is very much informed from
where you came from so try and keep like
the lessons that you have learned
in in mind like even if there was
someone you hate it or something that
just drove you nuts at least remember
like oh I really didn't like that so I'm
going to try not to do it again um lots
of people have given lots of advice
about entrepreneurship so I guess my my
real advice is you know if you feel that
that need then you should just go do it
go build something awesome great great
John if you have a lot of money to start
with on your own then you can put it
into your own planning and you find out
that you know hiring people and getting
them to join up your vision is is like
the hard thing and it's kind of a joke
but I've done three or four add related
companies before and they've been
successful in the thing about the ad
business that's interesting is it's
pretty much cash flow dominant and you
have to bootstrap to the point where
you're big enough to make money so you
can collect money attract advertisers
and pay your publishers if you can pay
your publishers a little bit more than
the other guys out there you know you'll
all sudden have a rolling business and
so that's kind of been what we've done i
would say that ad tech in general is not
a highly valued sector by most VCS
there's very few DC's that understand it
and so you will need to rely on your
personal personality skills to kind of
attract them and convince them that
investing in ad tech is is the way to go
but to apply it kind of any industry I
would say you know what I think and what
what GP just said is if you have a
belief in what you're doing and you're
good at attracting other people to share
your vision then get started and you can
probably find some way to get going for
a while it's a lot more fun to trial and
it is to just wish you had done it and
not do it Scott how do you think about
new businesses inside of your company
how have you seen the company evolve
well we're running this new adventure as
trying to do this a start-up mode in
company 6,000 why you get sales people
that are outselling it ahead of you and
it's just like oh stop it'll let us pick
two customers please that's been our
biggest problem after we did our
announcement PR announcements we've got
all these customers lined up that our
current offline customers that want
their data offline and we're trying to
like okay let's pick that one and let's
pick that one but we're trying with the
new shift CEO and our founders retiring
we've actually got up into a starter
mentality the group out here in cluster
cities kind of and part of the people in
Central Arkansas being consolidated and
isolated as much as possible from the
corporate structure so that we can move
fast and infill fast and keep going so
that's been my experience great so I've
been around this crazy train a few times
I've never actually I've been a fourth
employee but I've never started a
company but I've been involved in a lot
of rounds of funding and spent a lot of
time with VCS just cuz I think they're
interesting people yeah any of you see
is here series what I think I've
gathered and maybe you guys who've
actually started companies can correct
me but it seems like they invest in in
spaces like the good ones don't invest
in ideas at all they invest in like a
space and a team and and then
occasionally momentum so like you know
if if you created something in your
basement and it's getting a million
downloads a day that's momentum if
you're even if the space isn't hot and
and they don't know who you are you can
probably still get funding or if you're
if you're a known quantity and you've
executed before and they believe in you
I've seen people get investments
literally with no idea like hey I'm
gonna start a company but and you know
me I've succeeded twice you know and and
and that works too but I mean to
highlight how unimportant the idea is to
success I think I had a conversation
with a nice guy right right before I
came up here Ike and I lost his name my
head but I have this card and I was
describing what what metal markets does
about you know you know superfast
ingestion billions of events highly
predictable open source database amazing
visualizations with pivot to and he says
you know that's what everyone that
there's like 50 companies doing that and
I laughed I said yeah you're right
that's what everybody says and that's
why you can't invest in just ideas
because ever any I every idea you had
that you think is completely unique is
probably like been had like 20 times I
mean how many people tried to do drop
box before Dropbox exist in right it was
the wrong timing the wrong team the
wrong execution whatever but it was not
an it's not a new novel idea it's about
having the guts like you were saying to
go out and start it it's about having
someone who believes in you and like you
were saying being able to instill
confidence in a team and higher you know
execution is king and a hot space hot
space lifts all all boats as this it
anyway that was long a good that's great
well the first thing I would say is I if
you go through that process you will
learn things about yourself that you had
never thought you were going to learn
and perhaps don't really want to know
about yourself through this and so it is
an experience that will change you in
ways like people say about having
children right there's life before in
life after it and you are changed in
ways you don't you will never expect so
for that reason you know if you are
bored like I was starting a company is a
great thing to do you will not be bored
for several years what we did when we
started the company since we were
execution guys and not really known to
the VC industry even though we had been
at different you know starting phase
companies was rely on a proven execution
so the goal was to build a product start
selling it have some revenue have some
proof points and as you say it's not
really about the idea and so then this
this was like a marginal technique I
would say I I was hoping that was the
best strategy that I could come up with
the idea that if you had a product and
people
did maybe you get investment and that's
that's a cue know because couchbase was
out there with no product barely an idea
and they had VCS fighting to get in on
the round and I was like we were like
you know cut their bunches bunch of
chumps sorry for couchbase here have you
no pride in your own product right and
you know you have a competitor so that's
how always how they look and but they
had a seasoned guy they had a story of
being you know that having the guy out
who did memcache which actually wasn't
true and so they had one of my face
looks good it looks great so so part of
the theory was to have some money that
would allow us to feel when the market
started happening because a lot of the
companies I've been at there's that
moment when you actually start feeling
it you've got a product and people are
starting to beat down your doors and you
go out to a place like this and people
say oh yeah of course I need a fast
database what do you got so the idea was
to hold on until that started happening
and then find that right moment and
luckily enough being able to stay in the
business and my my other founder
co-founder screening vp of engineering
now his plan is to make sure we actually
stay in business and he thinks that's
the most important part of starting a
company which I can't disagree with
either that's great great stories so
let's let's open it up to questions from
the audience please go ahead and we've
got a mic over here if you want to say
your name and end your question I
actually don't have a question I was
just wondering if you could just go over
your names and your company's one more
time before we started please vine
Bukowski aerospike steve harris meta
markets Scott Jones axiom i'm john
christow mac from app lovin GP
brightroll hi I'm Brad palm Costa I'm
trying to figure out why everyone on the
panel is either connected thereof spike
or using your own spike is it uh okay
selection and this shows your dominance
in space or how did that happen the the
meetup was put together by aerospike and
we invited a bunch of folks that are
related to come talk about big data so
for aerospike could you see is your
biggest competitors i would say that
there's two families one is you know
before products in no sequel happened as
you've been hearing these stories it's
roll your own right because you've got a
very specific problem you can go after
it you can create a database or a data
storage layer that is exactly what you
need and I mean that's what what my
business was before founding this
company before no sequel started there's
still plenty of that around what I see
in the field a lot is quite a bit of
redness I think Redis is a great product
it sort of takes over where memcache
left off it has a rich object model it
has things like Louie udfs a lot of
people love it and it has a lot of great
miles on it what we see is the short
coming is SSD support which is to say
flash and how they do their clustering
but I see a lot of folks I was over
talking 2-way blow and some of the
Chinese guys they love rat us out there
they built these big 200 no dradis
clusters all in memory and that's how
big social networks and China work so
great set of products there HBase on
sort of on the slower side with little
more analytics great product for the
ease of use I mean that's where you see
that doesn't have the same scale
characteristics right so we see a lot of
stuff like that
hi my name is prasanna I'm an
entrepreneur working on my stealth
startup I found myself to be alone
because when i looked at the big data
the first observation i had was the
problem i was trying to solve was
actually done by existing clusters i'm a
hardware guy so my observation when i
started looking around big data was most
of the companies and the products were
around software and I didn't find
hardware companies solving bus problem
related to Layton sees capacity problem
related to the edge and more importantly
processing problems for 100 200 300
nanoseconds any comments on if I'm my
observation is right wrong no
it's not please go ahead you picked a
tough row to hoe I agree that there are
not a lot of hardware companies
targeting that particular problem the
the question that I think you need to
ask is what's the direction that the
software that the consumers of your
product are heading and how can you
align a hardware product with those
requirements so ad tech for example it's
in a little bit of a transition period
now where a lot of advertising company
traffic is coming from AWS so if you're
in any sort of cloud technology any sort
of hardware solutions off the table like
just by default it's off the table even
if you were to do things like okay you
have hardware and you're deployed a
software that software as a service
direct connected and AWS you're still
imposing a let's let's let's say 12 for
millisecond network penalty to get to
you at which point a 300 nanosecond
optimization isn't maybe that
interesting on the other hand as we move
more towards a programmatic buying I
should ask real quick what's your
background in advertising okay cool for
maybe those who aren't following
historically advertising is done sort of
as an internal auction within the ad
network increasingly that's moving to a
more programmatic thing where an ad
exchange will get a request like oh
here's a user who showed up we want to
show them an ad will farm it out to a
bunch of different associated people and
say do you want to bid on this yes no
collect the responses run an auction
amongst all of that and then return the
correct thing so when that happens
you're really starting to get into the
realm of optimizing for latency because
if you can get down to 0 I have an extra
two milliseconds to answer this question
then you can make you might be able to
make a different set of software
engineering trade-offs in the ad
decisioning platform to say am I going
to bid no bid how much am i willing to
pay how much data can I drawn from that
and if that happens
the technical background of AWS starts
to work against you like virtualization
overhead starts to be a pain like just
the unpredictability of AWS is trying to
become issue and the ability of people
to start drawing that into data center
traditional data center environments and
direct connect you know direct
single-mode fiber to your all of the
people you could possibly be in that
sort of real-time programmatic buying
arrangement with their you might have
something yeah I it I would say make
sure you know who your customer is I
mean one of the you know at least on the
software side a platform built for
everyone as a platform built for no one
I mean probably many of us have learned
that the hard way and I maybe not I
don't know I learned it the hard way so
you know my guess the people who care
most about nanoseconds similarly is
financial markets if you can find like
and they spend tons of monies probably
not a high volume play because most
people don't care about nanoseconds just
yet but certainly a foreign exchange
trader might or you know or someone
dealing with derivatives um so the way I
think with with an idea like that know
your customer and and go out and since
it's a small group of people it's either
government and intelligence probably our
financials my guess unless somebody can
think of somebody else who cares about
nanoseconds go go see those people go
talk to them and really understand what
they're trying to accomplish so that you
know what to optimize for and
potentially if you can get them excited
and those are the people who are willing
to invest yeah so one of the problems
you face sort of the half of what GP
said was I'm speed of light it's gonna
get you every time there's no way around
it I'm sorry I'm not smart enough you're
not smart enough so if you're going to
make a decision and report to a machine
outside of your own that's that's where
you sort of you're just kind of doomed
because optimizations on the nanosecond
level just will be swamped by any speed
of light delay between machines except
in a very very few very very small
subset of problems unless you have
problem domains you know beyond that so
I happen to talk to one of the guys who
does this
at a large for financial services firm
in New York and they said yeah we we do
our own chips and we don't even like a
six they're too slow we have the best
chip designers and we do our own custom
silicon period and that's a ten billion
dollar year investment we're happy to do
it so you're going to have to think
about who's competing with them and then
you've got this light speed problem
because there's only so many people who
are as connected from a speed of light
problem so it's a tough road to hoe not
to say don't do it I mean starting your
own database companies about is a
similar level of insanity so Scott how
much and and John how much of what
you're doing is in the cloud and using
AWS versus in-house for us we started
out using AWS it has you know kind of
upfront capital advantages we find that
for what we do price performance on AWS
is is worse than managed or hosted so
we've moved a couple things I mean the
latency thing and the rtb the real-time
video connection meant we wanted to
consolidate where we were so we've moved
more to manage toasting but we look at
AWS and you know ec2 and especially the
spot instance market as really potential
for good compute engine stuff so if
you're going to do Hadoop or something
like a Duke and you can do it on AWS
spot instances you are probably getting
a really good deal you can do a lot of
work that way and that's that's
currently our major usage usage of
amazon stuff we started with this
development in a dff AWS the advantages
on a dev startup is the capital outlay
and being able to throw away
I don't want that i want this and
redesign new things as you go and be
nimble and be able to pivot on that our
analytics stuff we are using spotting
instances on are heading to calculate
that most likely our analytics our data
major batch data store is going to come
back in-house and we'll keep our edge
processing either in AWS over in a coma
we're having some issues with AWS
because they only have so many form
factors and our particular data set has
a lot of entries not a lot of data so
that means you for particular and
aerospike you need more memory less
solid state disk because the indexes are
in memory that is on the solid state
disk so we're having to spend more money
on more nodes when we need because they
could give you two terabytes and 64 mega
memory and I need something gonna in
between what they doing but it's a great
place for startup it's a great place to
do development and get that and get
everything kind of solidified and then
we can go and make that capital outlay
saying we know exactly what we need
great other other questions please go
ahead hi thanks Frank McQuillan from
VMware I had a question I'd be
interested in the panel's commentary on
sequel on Hadoop we've been hearing a
lot about that lately we have Clara's
impala with hawk from from green plum to
be interested on your in your comments
on what you're seeing and what your
thoughts are on sequin hadoop wait it's
it's been I mean Impala I get well
sequels been on is a pig or high that's
equal in her dude hi I always mix those
two up I'm sorry I mean hive has been
around for a while I know a lot of
companies that use it
you know it's it works fine if you know
sequel it's slow as all get-out as
Mike's what I hear I don't use it that
much and then Impala i think is has
anyone i don't know is it even at one
point like is it out yet i know that you
can use market where there's actually
okay there's a demo actually up Cloudera
house you can actually do impala queries
i think they're running on an AWS
cluster you can run this week if you go
to the right place we've looked at it
extensively and you know there's a
there's a wide range of options and
there's also projects like their you
mentioned one but there's there's taz
there's stinger storm spark and shark
which are all kind of add-on layers to
give you some version of sequel on top
of a dupe it still kind of gum comes
down to what your underlying storage
layer is in HBase is HDFS what are you
doing and what I'd say is all of these
products that we've looked at on Hadoop
to do this and evaluating these projects
is a big chunk of work that we do are
not mature I mean you know Impala is
Justin it is new spark and shark things
that make hive 10 to 100 times faster
Impala is designed to do that tezz is an
Apache microsoft thing stinger as well
and also Twitter storm those are things
all designed to kind of change the
computation diagram of MapReduce into
something a little more flexible in
terms of a graph and be able to run the
sequel components at all the kind of
nodes out on the edge vs. it's just kind
of MapReduce you kind of tree up into
everything none of these products are
really kind of production level things
and so there there are options out there
that aren't
silly on hadoop that are you know you
mentioned greenplum and others there's
things like info Bray infinity be you
know there's meta markets obviously drew
it would they and then there are you
know and there's vertica which I think
HP owns that at one level another are
more sequel compliance so it depends
what you're looking for if you're
looking hey hey I have a bunch of
unstructured data and I'd like to do
sequel like things on it and I already
have a Hadoop cluster with my data in it
then maybe one of these new things is
worthwhile if not I'd say you know you
can look at some of these more
established that come from the BI OLAP
world or maybe oltp world and they might
work better and this this point so one
of the biggest things I think is one of
the problems with big data is that's it
you know etl is your lifeblood and where
do you put your data is it already in s3
well then redshift might be good for you
you know is it on your own hdfs cluster
well then maybe one of these you know
storm or impala is actually the thing to
look at or do you have something else
and then maybe you can look at a
different kind of solution so you know
it's a serious question and i think the
interesting thing to me is when you when
you have people that want to use sequel
and you want to use a real good version
of sequel then you need to investigate a
wide range of options but where your
data lives determines really what you
can do after that alright thanks like i
guess one of the keys is there is such a
huge number of people in enterprise you
guys are mostly AdTech which tends to be
more cutting edge but you know think
about goldman sachs think about JC
Penney they've got a ton of people who
know a sequel and they know it well so
now you've got this tons of data sitting
in places like Hadoop sitting on eight
in HDFS or HBase that they want to get
at to make their business run better to
understand their customers or whatever
better so that was sort of the root of
my question of this huge installed base
of enterprises with people who know
hypno Hadoop and how can those skills be
used to further their business
so I I recently talked to one of those
kind of shops got some interesting
queries from them and the guy was
talking to said our sequel is like the
guinness book of world records we have
individual queries that are this thick
they have 40-year investments in these
sets of queries and I don't think
they're ever going to move them out of
Oracle I mean it's not like sequel is
sequel they only they can't even change
from one kind of sequel to another so
you know I think my opinion is that
there's a certain amount of we're stuck
and people have to go beyond and try new
tools some of those will be cut down
stripped down versions of sequels some
of them will be new tools in general
because nobody is ever some of the
queries I've seen nobody is ever going
to run them unless they have the Oracle
source code great other questions
hi my name is a day I'm Annie I are at a
local incubator and I'm looking at
different databases to for an
application that will they'll have at
least one part will have real-time
predictive analysis and so I've been
looking at our spike and SCP Hana I just
want to see what you guys think about is
happy Hana thank you Mike he was asking
about a.s.a.p donna Brazile I was like
um I don't know I terracotta so meta
Marcus doesn't really compete hasn't
really run into you used to have his pot
already using we live evaluations I know
a lot of people have evaluated but
nobody who's deployed it I'm gonna say
yeah that's all I can say will you say
your name again and maybe the speakers
will be happy to talk with you
one-on-one about that my name is Hugh de
you dissing her like okay great all
right other questions and we're running
out of time so we'll we've got one there
and one up front here I'm Jewish Gupta
my question is what do you guys think of
Cassandra and warp space does it play in
we're and Cassandra first several months
and the biggest thing i think that
differentiates well i don't know exactly
what space a place and I think you have
to really be dedicated to it to make it
work well and the biggest thing that
differentiates from aerospike which is
what we went to after we gave up on
Cassandra is consistency so it's a p2p
you know kind of thing that has all the
java compaction stuff and garbage
collection stuff that you know we were
was referred to earlier but i would be
impressed with people who have a level
of commitment to make it work across
data center or replicate one thing i
will say is you know cross data center
replication is not solved by anybody
very well
right now so you know if that's what you
really need you need to go figure out
what works for you and maybe if your
Netflix and you have 17 system engineers
and whatever devoted to Cassandra it's
the answer but for us we switched
aerospike and had much more consistent
performance and that was the big selling
point and that will I'll ditto that is
it's about the performance and the
predictability of the performance when
you're doing ads and you're trying to
get things under 10 milliseconds you're
looking at the 95 99 percentile
performance and below 95 it does great
comment quickly on the netflix link so
Netflix's entire internal technology
model is based on stuff breaks all the
time hey ass monkey yeah the cast monkey
the chaos gorilla like they have in fact
an entire simian army waiting to break
stop um and Netflix fundamentally has a
very the problem they're trying to solve
they have very low cost of failure if
you get data that's like an hour old
it's inconvenient but no big deal if you
blow through an advertising frequency
cap and you show someone ten impressions
of an ad when you're only supposed to
show them to unfortunately someone's
going to pay for that and it's probably
you so they just by nature the problem
they're trying to solve and some by the
processes they've adopted which are in
many ways really good I think there's a
lot for the software engineering
community as a whole the model there
that they're kind of in a little bit of
a special case there may be more willing
to tolerate soft failures than what the
rest of us so um well a netflix uses
druid but one of the things that makes
cross data center a little bit easier
that i've seen is databases that are
essentially that don't support deletes
or updates like some of the goog like
Google bigquery and some of the other
and to a certain extent you're like
database it gets really really really
hard to do it well when you support
deletes and updates but when you when
you eliminate deletes and updates which
you can do in
if you look at span or DB it essentially
don't think it does fleets and updates
and certainly Google bigquery doesn't it
allows you to distribute these things
and not have some of the really gnarly
race skin it you still have summaries
conditions but some of the really gnarly
race conditions go away so you may want
to if you're if you're concerned about
multi data center you may want to try
and think about some of the databases
that have a essentially right only
obviously there's reading but no else
matters not available that's true it's
only paper but if we have they had to
rewrite TCP yeah and they had at an
atomic clock so you know you could use
drove instead yeah but she's get really
cool yes so what so we're about out of
time before we before we wrap up and I'm
sorry I know you had a question let's
take that and then I know all of you
guys are hiring so will you talk about
some of the skills and people that
you're looking for let's wrap up with
your question and then talk about that
to meet your demob sling briefly can you
explain your usage of Hadoop with spot
instances kind of more specifically we
are a few of you mentioned it what it
we're not exactly we're running a
nightly daily hourly jobs to consume
what our edge notes are producing and
where you're just doing spot instances
we don't keep a Hadoop cluster up we're
just using it to turn through all of the
350 million records that were doing the
day which is an alpha that we collected
a churning through that to create our
data set that's going to go in our
analytics so instead of paying for a big
cluster that's up all the time or for
normal instances we do spot instances
and cut our price down you spit up off
an image or something right scalars it
we we spin up however many nodes we need
there's different jobs that need
different numbers of nodes we pull our
data off of s3 which is where it staged
run all of a MapReduce job and then
write the data back to
to s3 and it goes away great alright so
let's wrap up with again your companies
and and what you are maybe hiring for so
our main hiring need right now is core
engineering and mostly that means C
programmers if you know C++ that's a
minus well no there's some nice people
who somehow learned in its ok but a lot
of core engineering we're down in
Mountain View meta markets we have since
we're a full stack solution we basically
have needs everywhere when I come here a
lot of people do but certainly an IT and
ops we have we have needs sort of back
in people who Pete the kinds of people
who like to write a database but our
database is written it and our ingestion
engine is written our Davis is written
Java an adjusted engine is mostly
written in Scala front-end visualization
stuff is a lot of d3 DVL coffeescript
but I would say if I were to ask the CEO
or number one need is sort of data
scientists and people can do
integrations and and can sort of
straddle the world of being super smart
technically and and understand and be
able to talk to customers great we are
actually holding an open house friday
for positions we're hiring from Hadoop
Big Data Hadoop clients to transactional
edge type engineers to you I front-end
developers we've traditionally not had
much of a front end because we're
dealing with bad stuff and the
traditional so that's open area to grow
in within the company and we're based
out of the foster cities where our
offices in San Francisco we wrap 11
based in palo alto we're looking for
data scientist and what i call data
anglers which are people that want to
learn more and become data scientist but
are still program or so people with math
CS stats backgrounds who want to do
machine learning you want to do
optimization algorithms logistic
regression type stuff and we mostly op
we're pretty language agnostic we like
Python Java we will take C++ programmers
without any apologies and you know i'll
send you a couple really good you know
it's a great environment sobre role
engineer he's hiring across the board
for pretty much everything front-end
stuff tends to be written in mixture
JavaScript and Ruby please don't ask me
about that i am absolutely the backend
dish corner of the world sort of the
mid-tier stuff for us is mostly Java and
Scala back end if it has a real-time
sort of Peace Corps ad serving is all in
C in general though we hire smart people
we're not super language-specific we've
kind of figure if you are pretty good
software engineer you'll be able to pick
up whatever language we have in short
order great well let's give our
panelists they warm round
you